Ryan Reynolds hit up comic-con itself
Paulo Brazil over the weekend where
things got kind of intense while
promoting his new film free guy a
barrier separating the crowd gave away
almost crushing him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that's terrifying
after the scary moment Ryan spoke to
Entertainment Tonight about this
surprising experience oh god yeah
there's a bit of a good
Gordon's collapsed and you know I think
it looked worse than it was and and all
I was worried about with the people that
were put but you could tell as they were
falling like oh they're gonna be fine
and I was like oh but that leg is gonna
go so I jumped up on the on the same but
it was yeah everyone was fine yeah I
mean you know my only job that Blake
said as I was leaving was just come home
in one piece so I that was my only jobs
oh my god yeah we're gonna we're gonna
try to make that happen
yeah yeah exactly another day yeah we
did another day anything could happen
yeah I mean just the way he jumped it it
was like a cat those reflexes Deadpool
true trained for this kind of thing I
mean that's what we should expect the
Ryan Reynolds I think right